[Música]
por aquí todavía transita el tradicional
pueblo nómada yoruk a través de estas
montañas en el sur de Turquía en un área
remota de planicies y pinos esta familia
instala su hogar una tienda hecha de
Telas tradicionales y sostenida por
postes de madera
hay que alinearlos bien si no la tienda
no va a ser estable los postes están
recién cortados y la gruesa tela del
exterior es de lana de Oveja para cubrir
el suelo utilizan distintas alfombras
no podría vivir encerrado en una casa o
en un apartamento no Me sentiría libre
el hombre yoruk proviene del verbo Turco
caminar una referencia al estilo de vida
nómada de esta minoría étnica a lo largo
del imperio otomano y del nacimiento de
la Turquía moderna la única constante de
este pueblo era su hogar en constante
cambio
los yoruk somos los guardianes de la
montaña protegemos su alegría
[Música]
estos pastores nómadas han vivido en
tiendas durante generaciones y solían
usar camellos para transportarse crían
ovejas por su leche y lana y todavía las
ordeñan a mano
mire presiona con mi pulgar y después
jalo con mis dedos para sacar la leche
hay que hacerlo sin lastimarla
ordeño más rápido que una máquina
la comunidad está repartida entre las
montañas pero todos llevan sus ovejas
alturas más elevadas para pastar los
yoruk están orgullosos de sus animales
gracias a ellos pueden tejer alfombras y
ropa colorida un oficio tradicional el
abuelo de esta familia incluso toca
flauta para el rebaño
los animales me escuchan
ellos también necesitan música se
alegran cuando me oyen con mi música les
digo hacia qué lado debemos ir
pero estos pastores ya no son
Bienvenidos en estas cadenas montañosas
algunos propietarios han cercado sus
terrenos impidiéndoles el paso
dicen que nuestros animales dañan las
áreas boscosas y los cultivos no nos
quieren aquí
actualmente solo una centena de yoruk
siguen siendo nómadas las nuevas
generaciones optan por las comodidades
modernas en vez de pasar las extremas
temperaturas de los inviernos y los
veranos en una tienda
tenemos tres hijos y espero que al menos
uno de ellos mantenga la tradición les
encantan los animales Entonces por lo
menos uno de ellos vivirá como nosotros
el amor por la naturaleza central para
la cultura de este pueblo también se
refleja en su bordado las pequeñas
flores que bordean este pañuelo están
inspiradas en la flora Silvestre de la
zona cuando llegue el otoño la familia
viajará de regreso hasta llegar al valle
con su rebaño